-Welcome back!
-Come on!
-You're here.
You're in New York City!
This is where
it all started for you.
-Oh my gosh, come on,
New York is my baby!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-How does it feel? Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
-I wanted to show a photo
that I found of you.
This is your home studio
when you first started out.
Is that possible?
-Yep.
-Yeah. Look at that.
-That's me.
-And look at the studio.
-That's about 16 years old.
My bedroom was the studio,
so there was
like a bed right here
and then all the gear
and the piano
and that was where I sat.
-So you could touch the piano
-And this is the closet.
-from your bed?
-Yes, from the bed.
Because it was tiny.
This is the closet
and I thought that, in order
to make a vocal booth,
I had to hang blankets,
so this was the blanket.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
I love that you did that.
I also have another photo
of the actual studio.
-Yes!
This is major!
-Do you have any songs
or any samples on here,
on these machines,
that you're like,
"Oh, no. If I ever play that,
it'll be so embarrassing"?
-There's definitely songs
I feel that,
if I play,
would be embarrassing.
I actually heard one today,
randomly.
My first song was on the
"Dr. Dolittle" soundtrack.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?!
-And it was called
"Rear View Mirror."
And, you know,
it was my first real attempt
at an official release.
And, when I listen to it now,
I kind of -- I could just --
I can hear all the insecurities
and all the things.
But it's beautiful, right,
insecurities?
-Yeah, you're starting out,
but also, that's a big break.
-It's a big deal.
It's an Eddie Murphy movie.
Let's do it.
-Let's go!
-Let's do it, right?
But now, you are one
of the best-selling artists
in the world
-Thank you.
-and, officially,
you were certified --
I want to say this --
the Most Certified
Female R&B Artist -- ready? --
of the Millennium.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Of the millennium!
-I have to be honest.
I had to look up
the word millennium.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "How many years
is a millennium?"
-"Let me be clear
about what millennium means."
This is major. Millennium is --
-Congratulations.
-I was feeling
really proud of that.
My husband actually
surprised me with it.
Somehow, he got the news first
and I was washing dishes
in the kitchen
and he comes up over to me
with the camera
and he's always on his phone,
trying to get some type
of video.
You know, those husbands?
[ Laughter ]
And so I'm washing the dishes
and he comes over
and he has the camera
all in my face.
"So, how do you feel?"
And I'm like, "Huh?
[ Laughter ]
I'm washing the dishes."
And he's like, "No, really, what
do you feel like right now?"
I was like, "I don't --
I don't -- I'm just --
I'm soapy?
I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm soapy.
"What are you up to?"
-And so he finally
broke the news to me
and I was like
so proud, but shy,
but like excited
and I worked
all my life for this.
-Look at this.
Yeah, exactly, right?
-Since that right there!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's where it started.
-Yes!
-That's awesome!
-[ Laughs ]
-And you're going on tour
this summer.
-Yes.
-It's a big deal.
-No, it's amazing.
I'm going on tour first time in,
I guess, two years,
since all of the,
you know, I mean, maybe more.
At this point, how long has
the pandemic been like?
[ Laughter ]
-We all stopped counting.
But, please. We're happy
that you're on tour, though.
-Okay, I'mma be on tour
and, since that,
it was originally
the Alicia Tour
because that was the album
I put out.
And, since then,
I put out my album called Keys,
so now it's going to be
the Alicia Keys Tour.
-That's what I'm talking
about, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, you got to add Keys
in there.
You did it one night
at the Apollo.
-Mm!
-Did you rub the stump?
Did you do the whole thing?
-I definitely --
You have to rub the stump.
If you don't rub the stump...
-Then you're a fool.
-Nah, it's not going to be
a good night.
-You have to get good luck.
-Yes!
-I mean, how was that?
I know you
had Egypt record something.
What was it?
-It was
"Somewhere Over the Rainbow."
-No, yeah, that was.
-So, Egypt is my 11-year-old.
-He's 11 already?
That wild, right?
-Crazy.
-And so he's playing piano
and he's singing
and he's writing songs
and the whole thing.
So this was his first song
that he recorded
in the studio with me,
like, you know, singing.
-"Somewhere Over the Rainbow."
I mean, it had me
just tearing up
and it's not even my kid.
-Nah.
[ Laughing ] I can imagine.
-I definitely had a moment
where I was like, "Wow!"
Because I realized that
like his voice is never going
to sound like that again.
He's never going to have
that place where it's kind of
he hasn't quite hit puberty.
It's still really sweet.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And I was just witnessing like
a moment in time
that probably
will never come back,
so, it's really beautiful.
It's so sweet.
You got to hear his voice.
-And then,
your other baby, Genesis.
-Genesis.
-Does he want to be
in the limelight or he's like,
"I'm cool"?
-Genesis doesn't like anybody.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
-Doesn't like anybody.
-He's not for the games,
alright?
He's not for any
of the showcasing, no.
Don't take pictures of him.
Don't ask him to like
go be nice to people, no.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he doesn't do that, no.
-So he's a little tough guy.
He's a hot pepper.
And so, after the Apollo show --
It was really
an incredible show.
It was so electric
and alive and special
and he was watching
from the side of the stage
because, somehow, the Apollo,
you have to be over 16
to be in the audience,
-Is that right?
-which was new --
I didn't realize it.
So he's at the side
of the stage, you know,
just respectfully
following the rules.
And I come out at the end
of the show and he says,
"Mommy, why didn't you
bring me out?!"
And I was like, "Who are you?
[ Laughter ]
What?!
-You go, "You don't do this."
-You don't even want --" I said,
"Do you want to come out?"
He's like --
I was like, "Right now?"
I said, "Okay.
I'll do one more song,
so you can come out,"
and he was like, "Okay."
And then, right when I walked,
"But I'm scared now."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "No, don't be
scared now."
No, come on, man, let's go."
-"Genesis, you set this up."
We have a little video of you
and Genesis here.
Check this out --
Alicia Keys and Genesis.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hello.
-I can't -- No.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-"Hello."
That's the voice.
By the way,
I can't believe he was up there
saying hello to anybody.
-Right?
-Such a shocker.
So it was sweet to see him
kind of, you know, go for it.
-I love that you brought him.
That's awesome.